welcome to sas talks money on
valuetainment i'm your host adam sosnick
and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode
we're gonna make sure that you have a
game plan for your money
let's talk money
all right question for you when i bring
up the word budget
what comes to mind right budget because
let me tell you something when i ask
people this question
not a lot of positive connotations
surrounding the word budget let me give
you an example when i talk to people
here the type of words they use to
describe
having to do a budget they say that it's
not fun that it's boring
that it's restrictive that it's negative
and it's just straight up
sucks well let me tell you something the
only thing worse
than doing a budget is not doing a
budget
all right so let's get into a couple
quick stats
stats for you according to a gallup poll
two-thirds of american families
do not do a written budget straight up
even worse
according to forbes three-quarters of
americans that's 75 percent
live paycheck to paycheck did you catch
me on that
two-thirds of american families don't do
a written budget and 75 percent of
americans live paycheck to paycheck
do you think there's a correlation with
that
i straight up think there is a
correlation with that
so we understand that budgeting is not
fun it's not that cool it's restrictive
but it's something you have to do in
fact i talk about the six principles of
wealth this is number one
having a game plan for your money so
today we're going to do a budget today
but we're going to understand something
we're going to make it fun we're going
to make it easy we're going to make it
effective
and it's going to help you get better
with your money
so can we all agree that we should start
doing a little bit more budgeting
or what i call having a game plan for
your money do we agree with that can i
get a comment can i get a yes
because i think you should so let's keep
going
there's something that i've recognized
as the biggest problem
when it comes to budgeting and the
reality is this the biggest problem that
i've seen is you just straight up don't
want to face the truth
you don't want to face the music there's
a problem with that
you don't want to look under the hood
like you've ever been driving down the
street and there's something going on
with your car and you're like i don't
know what that is but
i'm just gonna pretend i didn't hear
that i'm just gonna and i'm not gonna
deal with it
that's the thing with the budget you
don't wanna like actually open up the
hood
get in there and be like damn i thought
i was making 50 grand a year but i'm
only making 42.
damn i thought i was only spending 30
grand a year but i'm actually spending
47. it's like oh yeah
what's going on here a lot of people
don't want to look under the hood
and face the truth it's cool i get it
but you need to be honest
and you need to be accurate with the
amount of money you're making
and the amount of money you're spending
there's only you're going to know you're
the only person that's going to know
or you and your significant other so why
lie to yourself
all right cool so we understand that
budget is a game plan for your money
majority of americans aren't straight up
not even doing a budget and even higher
percentage of americans are living
paycheck to paycheck
so why be that person why have live your
life that kind of way
so if i'm telling you that principle
number one of the six principles of
wealth is having a game plan for your
money
let's implement this game plan alright
so what we have here now are some
some tips some tools that you could
utilize to have a better game plan for
your money first and foremost
there's something called the 50 30 20
rule the 50 30 20 rule that's this
little pie chart right here
we'll probably have it up on the screen
for you as well 50 30 20 world now
what's the 50 30 20 rule i'll tell you
what the 50 30 20 rule is
it basically stipulates this that 50 of
your income
should go to your needs 30 of your
income
can go to your wants but 20 of your
income needs to go to your financials
so let's break that down a little bit
let's unpack that a little bit when we
talk about 50
goes to your knees what are your needs
what are your needs these are things you
just straight up can't live without all
right
these are things that are essential and
there's things that you require in your
life right what do you require what do
you need what's essential
well a roof over your head right you
need transportation you need to be able
to get around you need food
right these are things that are straight
up essential so now let's talk about the
which is your wants now your wants are
things that you can live without
but the things that you kind of want in
your life things that you desire
something that you really really want to
have but they're not essential they're
not required
this is going shopping this is going to
games these are just spending
money these are wants but not
necessarily needs cool there's once we
want to live the best life we want to
have a good time we want to go out and
party
we want to have a good time i get it but
those are wants and last but not least
you got 20
that goes to your financials now what
are your financials this is what i call
the big three
paying off debt saving that money and
investing that money all right so if you
just do the math here
80 percent of your budget can go to your
needs and your wants
twenty percent should go to your
financials so you understand that
something with this fifty thirty twenty
rule
it doesn't mean you can't go live your
best life it just means
limit it limit it fifty percent of your
needs
thirty percent of your wants twenty
percent on your financials
easy peasy lemon squeezy there's a
template for you
right now a 50 30 20 rule that you can
implement in your life
off top cool moving right along let's
talk about the dynamics of a budget
first and foremost let's just actually
define
a budget what is a budget a budget is
your income minus your expenses
i feel like vanna white over here your
income
minus your expenses your income in green
and your expenses in red so let's talk
about your income minus your expenses
aka a budget
so what i talk about with your income is
you need to be focusing on making that
money that's income
welcome to america ladies and gentlemen
it's all about capitalism
it's all about making that money and
this is your offense
right so if you're a sports fan you
understand that you want to put up
points
on the board right this is your offense
you want to make that money
now when you talk about expenses you
want to limit your expenses
this is your defense right this is
limiting the amount of money that's
going out the door this is limiting
spending that money this is limiting
consumerism so i'll give you a sports
analogy we know that i use sports
analogies around here
i love basketball right so who remembers
a guy called steve nash right steve nash
was a two-time
nba mvp in the early to mid 2000s i'm
guessing probably 2005
2004 or 2006 somewhere around that range
two-time mvp
now what was the problem with steve nash
steve nash's team with amari stottemeyer
and sean marion had a great team they
would put up the most points in the
league they put up 120 points a game
but what was their problem they would
give up 125 points a game
so here you go you're scoring you're
winning all these awards that's great
but you can't win the big one because
you give up too much points so what's my
point for you with this
income minus expenses it doesn't matter
if you make a hundred grand a year
if you spend 110 grand a year right
you're giving up a lot of
points on the other side but on the flip
side let's say you make on average the
average american makes 50 grand a year
if you make 50 grand a year but you only
spend 40 grand
well yo you're winning you're winning
the money game right there you're
implementing a budget you're limiting
your expenses
so boom here we go that's your offense
versus defense income minus expenses
so we're going to go down the list here
so income let's start with income
when you're talking about income how do
you make income when you make income by
working
all right i don't think many a lot of
people are just sitting around making
money doing nothing unless you're
collecting unemployment we won't get
into that right now
but if you're just making income you got
to work right you got to work
now when it comes to work a lot of times
i ask people do you have a career
or do you have a job so i'm asking you
do you have a career
or do you have a job so what do we mean
by that so like i have a career i've
been working in financial services for a
life settlement company
for 13 years right my company is great
at this i have a career
this is what we do now there's been
times in my life where i had a job i was
a substitute teacher
right i was a club promoter i did
stand-up comedy i did some nightlife
stuff i worked at a hotel those were
jobs
now i have a career so one of the things
that people ask me is like how can i
make more money right
how can i make more money well let me
tell you something a couple different
things
number one the riches are in the niches
what do i mean
be the freaking best at what you do when
i was growing up did i say i want to be
the number one
life settlement guy in the planet no but
i found myself
entering to this world where i was like
alright cool i got this job
let me get good at it let me get really
good at it let me start making some
serious money here
let me specialize in this thing boom
next thing you know i'm making six
figures and then some
every single year because i was a
specialist speaking of specialists
there's a difference between being a
specialist so if you're i'm the best
lawyer in the world
i'm the best architect in the world i'm
the best editor in the world i'm a
specialist straight up i am the best
i'm the best stand-up comedian in the
world i'm the best basketball player in
the world
i am great at what i do versus someone
who's a jack of all trades what i'm
gonna be a jack of all trades
kind of like when i was in my twenties i
did a little stand-up comedy i was a
substitute teacher
i did some club promoting i was at a
sports agency so people say yo what does
sas do they're like i don't know he does
a lot of who knows
so what do you do what do you do are you
a specialist
are you like the bomb at something or
are you just kind of jack of all trades
in miami where i'm from
there's so many people that are jack of
all trades what do i mean by that well
they're a bartender
but then they do real estate but then
they're gonna invite you to their club
but then they're gonna you know maybe
fix your house and then they oh they got
a side hustle credit card business it's
like dude what are you doing
focus on something be a specialist at
something so we're talking about income
now people people ask me how can i make
more income
well cool be a special at something have
a career with something
rather than just a job now there's
nothing wrong with having a job
and collecting a paycheck let's talk
about that a little bit if you collect
the paycheck you understand that you're
getting paid
once or twice a month cool stable steady
boom five grand a month
boom five grand a month boom five grand
a month cool that's something that's
stable
that you can have predictable income but
the difference with that
is are you irreplaceable or expendable
let me say that again are you
irreplaceable or expendable so a lot of
times
what's going on in america today all
over the world people are getting fired
unemployment claims are all-time high
so they're looking at you know my list
of who's working for me who's working
for me here okay this first person
oh she's the bomb we're not we're not
letting her go this one right here he's
kind of a slacker
he might be the first in the chopping
block so these are the type of
conversations that ceos have
all right or cfos have when they're like
hmm what should we do with this person
so are you irreplaceable are you awesome
at what you do
are you expendable all right if you're
expendable you might bounce from job to
job
right like we talked about job to job
job the job but if you're irreplaceable
inexpendable straight up you have a
career for the rest of your life so i
know if things don't work out at my
company that have been for 13 years
i'm not worried at all because i'll have
a line of people out the door being like
oh you come work for me now bro
okay that's the difference between being
a specialist and being
irreplaceable versus being someone who's
a jack of all trades
and just someone who's replaceable and
just kind of does their nine to five
thing and collects their paycheck so
moving right along you're collecting
your paycheck you're making that money
you're making income cool i applaud you
that's awesome now here's something else
on how people make money so people make
money on sales
commissions or their seasonal business
so for me
i make a lot of money on sales and
commissions so there might be months
where i'm making
40 50 grand a month crazy amazing
awesome month but there might be months
where i'm making
you know four or five grand a month
right so money can kind of come in the
door and out like that
versus something that's consistent now
also in miami where i'm from there's a
lot of seasonal work
we call season basically seasons from
november to may right so you have like
bartenders or waitresses or club
promoters or like yo i'm making 10 grand
a month this is sick this is awesome i'm
making that money i'm gonna live it up
and then what happens is summer hits in
miami and now you know they're making
two grand a month
or three grand a month or maybe even
worse so they're making high peak
incomes certain times of the year
and then very low income other times of
the year so my question to you is
when you're making these big pops 10
grand 20 grand
50 grand there's been months where i've
made 80 100 grand in a month
i don't just ball out like it's the last
time that i'm ever gonna make money i
save that money and i make sure
that it lasts cool so my advice to you
is if you work in sales
and commissions or you have seasonal
income is understand that that needs to
last you for the entire year
not that month and you need to save that
money let's keep moving on we now we
got the gig economy now you're making
you know you might get money
uh driving uber you're driving lyft
you're doing little side hustles you're
getting gigs on fiverr you're editing
you're producing you're doing little
things
boom boom boom it's not your main job
it's not your main career
but i respect the side hustle mentality
respect kudos to you maybe you're making
50 grand in real life
and a real job and now you make another
20 grand that's 70 grand that can be an
amazing situation where you're paying
off debt with that extra 20 grand
or you're saving that money for a down
payment cool respect to you if you got a
side
hustle and i know where my real estate
people at there's a lot of people that
invest in real estate
next thing you know they're getting
rental income boom boom boom boom boom
they're making rental income
respect all right that's cool there's
some people straight up they get money
from their family
from their parents all good but just
understand that might come
to an end at some point so are you
budgeting with that in mind
last but not least when people say sas i
gotta make that money what do i do what
do i do
one of the things i always say is that
your network is your net worth
your network is your net worth who are
you hanging out with
who do you work closely with who are the
top five people you associate with
it has been said that if you add up the
top five people that you hang around
with the most
that is a telltale sign of where you'll
be in the future so ask yourself yo who
am i hanging out with am i hanging out
with winners
and go-getters and hustlers and money
makers and people that move the needle
and movers and shakers
or am i hanging out with my same loser
friends from high school that smoke weed
every day that whatever they work their
job
they're just kind of going through the
motions they don't read they don't
improve they don't get better they're in
12 fantasy football leagues
they're going out to the party they have
zero room for improvement in their life
so ask yourself who you're hanging out
with all right so you know who i'm
talking to if you know what i'm talking
about here
and if you have the type of person
that's like you know what that makes
complete sense
it's all good to go ghost on your
friends for six months it's all good to
go ghost on your friends
for 12 months and say yo i got to
improve myself and do what i got to do
all right so there's that that is all
income that's
offense that's making money that's
careers as riches are in the niches
that's not being a jack of all trades
that's being a specialist that's your
network is your net worth
it's understanding that income is the
name of the game and that is offense and
that's where you should focus
and now it's time for the red side of
the board which is your
expenses as we covered at the beginning
you want to limit your expenses your
expenses
are your defense right you don't want to
spend that money you want to save that
money
but understand that everybody has the
same big
three expenses now what are the big
three expenses you ask well i'll tell
you well number one is your housing
everybody needs a place to live so when
we're talking about housing we're
talking about your rent
your mortgage we're talking about
utilities internet cable
if you're a home owner you understand
that you have taxes insurance and
maintenance
collectively this should be at the very
most 33
of your income so right so most people
spend between 25
and 33 of their net income on their
housing
cool that's housing that's one of the
that's number one of the big three
expenses what's number two
number two is your transportation your
transportation is how you get around how
you move
and operate every single day these are
your car payments this is your insurance
this is your gas this is your uber this
is your lift this is going on a subway
this is taking a freaking bus
if you still do that cool this should be
at the very most
10 to 20 percent of your income that's
number two
of your big three expenses all right
number three in the big three expenses
number three
is your food and beverage your f and b
now what is your f and b
this is your groceries this is dining
out or eating in or cooking at home
this is do you go to the bars or clubs
on the weekend this is everything you're
doing
with eating and drinking and your food
and beverage that's that
so this should be at the very most 10 of
your income if you have a fancy palette
it might be as much as 12 15 but i
encourage you to keep that below
10 of your income cool so those are your
big
three expenses everybody that's watching
this has the same
big three expenses boom boom boom boom
boom so if you can understand that those
are your big three expenses you are now
75 of the way done with your budget
congratulations
you're almost there so you understand
you want to live your best life you got
it you want to live in a place you want
to live you want to drive what you want
to drive
you want to eat and drink what you want
to drink but those decisions have
repercussions
because you only have so much room in
your budget now what else do you have in
your budget after you do your big three
everyone has other expenses that they
need to account for people have
insurance whether you have health
insurance life insurance
disability insurance people have child
care school
pets all those types of things you got
cell phone apps gym recreation
entertainment
shopping beauty these are all
consumerism materialism
spending that money living your best
life and the way you want to live
cool i respect that so understand that
these are things that you have to
account for
within your budget cool moving right
along
let's talk about some stuff that i have
right here the whole name of the game
is that i'm more concerned about your
net worth than your netflix
let's unpack that a little bit i'm more
concerned about your net worth
than your netflix that actually has a
double meaning what do i mean by that
i'm more concerned about you making that
money
networking and working on your side
hustle than i am with you
just netflixing and chilling all right
cool what i also mean by that
i'm also not concerned about your 10
expenses every single month
it's not a big deal with netflix i'm
worried about your big
three expenses so you'll hear a lot of
people you got to cut out the little
things and you know
the two dollar cups of coffee you got to
cut that out your netflix that's 10
bucks
who gives a about that okay focus
on the big
three expenses and focus on your net
worth now when we're talking about net
worth what is net worth
well net worth is the entire name of the
game my friends
nobody cares about what you make this
week this month this year they want to
know what your net worth is now what is
your net worth
your net worth are your total assets
minus your total
liabilities i'll say it again your net
worth or your assets
minus your liability so you can see down
here your net worth
assets in green liabilities in red so
when you're doing your budget understand
there's a big
picture in mind it's not about every
single month or every single week or
every single year
it's about working on your collective
net worth
overall so when you're doing your budget
you understand your income you total it
up boom
what's your total cool i made seven
grand this month amazing
i made 6 500 bucks this month i made
five grand this month i made 10 grand
be accurate and be honest with how much
you make
and then on your expenses total it up
how much did you spend this month
right be accurate and don't lie to
yourself that's your income minus your
expenses and i'll leave you with this
there's a great quote by a good buddy of
mine his name is kelly olynyk he plays
in the nba with the miami heat they're
in the finals right now
respect he said this he said how much
does it cost to be you
how much does it cost to be you does it
cost two grand a month does it cost
five grand a month does it cost 10 grand
a month so what he encourages you to do
is
add it up see how much it costs to be
you
look back at it and let's figure out how
you can make it cost
less to be yourself that's the whole
point of doing the budget
adding up your income figuring out your
expenses and cutting out what you need
to cut out
and add more money if you need to add
more money this is america baby
if you're only making 50 grand a year
and you want to make 100 grand you can
figure it out i promise you that so it's
all about your net worth
with that being said let me give you my
final takeaways when it comes
to having a game plan for your money aka
a budget
number one a budget you do it once a
month and it's on the first
of the month first of the month is game
day i've talked about this before that
i learned about the first of the month
from one of my favorite rap groups of
all time
bone thugs and harmony they had a song
called the first of the month
and i remember saying like what's going
on in the first of the month well rents
do all right so you gotta be prepared to
get ready to pay your bills
that's the first of the month shout out
to both dogs and harmony i know that
they're watching this video
they're big fans of valuetainment
respect number two
what i would encourage you to do is do a
big budget i talked about your big three
expenses i'm not worried about your
little
frappuccinos or your lattes or your
netflix i'm worried about your big
three expenses housing your
transportation and your food and
beverage
those are your big three expenses focus
on a big budget
not the little things cool number three
i put this here for a reason because you
need to add up your last three months if
you're like dude i've never done a
budget in my life
i got no clue what's coming in the door
i don't know clue what's going out the
door i've never done this
so here's what you do you add up all
your expenses
all your income everything for the last
three months that's why it's number
three
pay stubs bank and credit card
statements bills receipts you add it up
you get an idea of what's going on cool
you add it up and now you got something
to work with you have a template
to work from that's number three your
last three months number four is to
understand that things change you got to
be flexible
there are certain months of the year
where you're going to be spending more
than other months like right
christmas is coming up we got to
understand you got presents you got
hanukkah for my jewish friends
we got new years you're gonna walk out
and party then you've got february it's
valentine's day
march april you got spring break then
it's summer you're gonna do a summer
vacation
so understand that every single month is
different and you have a little
flexibility within your budget
so things change number five this is
huge huge huge
write it down straight up write it down
you say don't i do a budget in my head
i kind of know what i'm making no no no
no that does not work you need to write
it down
now if you're not trying to like if
you're not old school like me i use
straight up use a pen and paper
straight up pen and paper but if you're
not you could use a pen and paper
you could use a spreadsheet worksheet
there's people that use an envelope
system
that's if you like cash or you can use
straight up apps a lot of people use
apps you got apps like mint
or ynab or every dollar these are
straight up budgeting tools
that you can utilize and they're free
check them out that's that that's number
five
and last thing i've said this before and
i'll say it again
you need to budget like brady what do i
talk about with brady who am i talking
about
tom brady the goat the greatest football
player of our generation
he's not the biggest he's not the
fastest he's not the strongest but what
does he do he has a game plan
going into every single game he doesn't
just show up be like all right i'm
playing for tampa now i'm playing the
saints
let's figure this thing out he knows
what he needs to do every single game so
what's my point for you with that
is that there's 12 months in a year and
you need to go in every single month
like it's game day
and you need a budget like brady
that's it that's budgeting that's having
a game plan
for your money if you can do a game plan
every single month
and implement a budget i promise you'll
end up in the hall of fame
and be the goat of budgeting just like
brady with that being said
if you have not seen my episode on the
six principles of wealth
how to win the money game check that out
right here and if you have not seen
my episode on 10 things that are killing
your wealth check that out right here
and if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics please do so
below
and smash that like button while we're
at it and last but not least i promise
you if you do a budget every single
month
you'll end up saving that money all we
talk is money